so many people dream of seeing new york
city one day here we all are but there
are people who still want to get here
and our next story is about a
nine-year-old who made it happen
um the week reports
shepherd culver
dreamed of seeing the statue of liberty
so this summer he and his dad hopped on
their bikes and they drove on over oh
that's right they drove all the way from
washington state what road the journey
was 3
300 miles and it took
19 weeks
and it was made even sweeter because
their first attempt was cut short when
shepard was diagnosed with diabetes but
he's doing great and he made it this
time
and i just i love this story it's
amazing i i wonder you know
i'm so inspired look at them you're so
inspired to do something amazing like
this but you know 3 000 mile that's all
long that is a big big commitment and i
just
um i'm proud of them i don't know that
but
i'd love to think that i could do
something like this this is amazing
think about that memory that he has
created with his nine-year-old son that
for the rest of his life he's gonna
think about that time he went from
washington i'm from washington i know i
know how far the pacific northwest is
and on a bike make it all the way out
here that isn't give them a round of
applause that's amazing
by the way commitment
would you ever do that with your kids
you know what after seeing that and as
sentimental as it is
no absolutely not
crazy i barely go around the block
i really fear what my kids would do if i
told them this was happening i
i i would literally have to get that
young gentleman on the phone and have
him like give it real to my girls i
oh what what kids do this what parents
are able to inspire this in their kids
this makes me feel like a dysfunctional
parent with major aspiration goals so
good for you
wow that was incredible
that was incredible that would not be
easy no not at all no well nate burleson
thank you so much for being here thank
you so much and obviously catch him on
cbs mornings um every weekday on a show
that is just we're so proud also to be
linked together you know because in a
lot of um markets and cities it's cbs
mornings and then us so what an honor to
be sibling shows
what an honor to be uh working with you
and i just more and more and more yeah
no doubt wake up with us and stay with
you guys right yeah
[Music]
you